ich bin heute mittag trotz abgegangen
und sie wird diese nachricht habe video
für dich ich dachte erst mal für op
bruder lernt vielleicht erst mal deutsch
gehalten bild geschickt und auf diesem
bild war zu sehen ansage an konkreter
schrägstrich luca von dem kanal senioren
zocken und wird vielleicht wirkt habe
ich vor einiger zeit ein video
hochgeladen wo ich auf ein gameplay
video von senioren zocken reagiert habe
ln wie kann es schaffen meine damen und
herren sie kaputt einfach nur geradeaus
fahren und anscheinend hat dieser kanal
mit den senioren die dort games zocken
und mitbekommen dass sich über wie ein
video gemacht habe warum sollen folgen
den anlage videos hochladen
dann halt auf den kanal gegangen hat
dann halt das video entdeckt ansage an
congstar oder denkt man halt er trug
eine ansage ist eigentlich immer negativ
belasten das ganze video wurde bei einer
stunde hochgeladen und es hat einfach
27.000 aufrufe ohne übelste bewertung
normalerweise werden ansage videos die
negativ behaftet sind ja ein bisschen
kontrovers er bewertet und darunter wird
wieder viel diskutiert allerdings teams
hier anscheinend positiv gemeint aber
ich will gar nicht mehr warum reden wir
hören einfach mal direkt rein
[Applaus]
hallo vielen dank dass du senioren
stalking ein video mit der peene gemacht
hatte
ich habe doch der video mit der spd
gemacht also die bedanken sich hier dass
ich ein video mit der er will ihn
gemacht habe er wird wie hier bei jb sie
nicht kennt das was ich gemacht habe ist
auf ein video von der ebenen reagiert zu
haben aber ich weiß auf jeden fall was
sie meint und weiter meine eigene oma
mir genauso an wie früher als ich in
meinen kleinen cousins gespielt habe als
meine oma einkaufen war und sie kamen
wieder meine aber wir schauen dafür
video mal weiter an von evelyne wirklich
auch noch persönlich bei mir begangen
also weiß ja wie das mit den senioren
ist die haben immer ganz selten seien
also erstmal wird sich öffnen wo noch
persönlich bei mir bedanken alter ich
weiß nicht wie ich das anstellen will
gespannt und wir wissen ja alle wie das
mit den senioren ist immer ganz selten
leise und wirklich sehr fit mit der
eigentliche kanal die in deutschland
verfolgen leider laden die halt nur ein
oder zweimal wöchentlich videos hoch
aber dafür sind die video für
unterhaltsame also ich finde es so
sympathisch aber wir schauen mal weiter
ihr kurs auch deine videos an und ich
hoffe wir bleiben in verbindung und du
schaust weiter und ja kostelic audi wird
meine videos direkt an die betreiber des
kanals senioren doppel oder an dich
liebe damen enthält so witzig wenn die
auf ein video von mir reagieren würde
nur dann reagiere ich wieder auf das
video nur reagiert 100 werte oltra
witzig aber okay die meinen dass sie
sich auch meine videos anschauen darf
ich natürlich also wirklich ich werde
euch weiter verfolgen und wir haben so
viele abonnenten bekommt es durch die
decke
luca wunderbar hast du das gemacht wir
werden dir also bis zum nächsten mal
leute mein herz mein herz weint gerade
der kanal senioren zocken bedanke mich
bei mir dass ich ein video was wir
gemacht haben die abonnenten hoch
gegangen sind ein paar sekunden später
okay
das krad wir hatten vorher so 41.000
haben sie täglich x 300 x 140 x 60 x 118
114 neue abonnenten gemacht und wir
merken und vor meinem video über sie
hatten sie 42.000 dann habe ich das
video hochgeladen
rom 19 abonnenten an einem tag an dem
weiten tag nach dem video 2000
abonnenten damit müssen wissen
abgeflacht 4000 2109 oder 1100 1000
plattform jetzt haben die 86.000 leute
durch mein video haben sie einfach ihre
abonnenten anzahl von einer woche
verdoppelt
also wie krank fällt ihr denn bitte also
hier bei großem herz an euch ich hoffe
ihr versteht was wir alles nicht gegen
die abgesprochen war oder irgendwie ein
werbevideo oder eine kooperation ist ich
habe wirklich am kanal von denen
entdecken dass mir gedacht taylor könnte
man über cool drauf reagieren und jetzt
kann man diese antwort und einfach nur
hammer atef erfüllt mein herz mit liebe
mein halt auch in dem video von mir als
ich darauf reagiert habe luca du machst
dich über die lustig kam sie auch in den
kommentaren aber nein leute dass es
nicht über die lustig machen das uns
einfach mit denen lachen weil ich meinen
die hand die hand der verstanden die
haben verstanden dass ich das überhaupt
nicht böse gemeint habe also besonders
weil die kommentare unter dem anlage
video an erst mal hab ich halt vor 50
minuten runter geschrieben
hahaha schöne greet erleuchten das
komplette team oder kann man schon
direkt die antwort schöne grüne trikot
haye wieder schöne enorm kraft wie
freundlich diese communitys wie
freundlich ihr gleich freundlich die
community von denen uns natürlich haben
wir wie alle hier was drunter schreiben
wieder alle feiern eine ewigkeit steckte
leute das hinnimmt gar kein ende mit den
ganzen kommentaren was ihr alle
geschrieben haben
kollegah turniersieg innerhalb von
städten ich war schon vor luca hier wäre
auch bitte leiten ok hatten ja klar als
natürlich waren schon vor mir da ein pc
1000 leute abonnenten aber ich glaube
das hat denen jetzt halt natürlich nicht
schlecht getan da fährt noch mehr leute
dazugekommen bin ich glaube das
motiviert natürlich auch vielleicht
öfter videos hof innern bin ich der
einzige der schon vor luca kannte okay
gibt natürlich schon wird wieder wie
auch ganz lustig bin auch durch luca auf
euch gekommen 53 34 live jetzt schickt
luca die ganzen ferien auch corp carolin
hey ich weiß nicht was solche kommentare
wollen ich weiß jetzt dass negativ
gemeint ist oder keine ahnung was aber
ich denke mal es ist ein bisschen
negativ gemeint weil sie ist ja immer im
bilde begriff liebe caroline ganz kurze
persönliche nachricht an sich es tut mir
leid dass ich auf den kanal den jahren
trocken der anscheinend nur die ihr
gehört meine community hingelegt aber
den gezeigt habe was nicht für coolen
content machen wird auf jeden fall nicht
wieder vor all dies ein hoch auf luca
dann ihr habe ich diesen kanal gefunden
luca wird sich bestimmt so freuen cooles
video weiter so und wer sieht das video
von luca aufkommen wer gibt da sicher
ein defektes reichlich hoch also das
video hat 50 cent das sind einfach
senioren die sich damit überhaupt nicht
wirklich auskennen die bedanken sich
dafür dass ich leute auf ihrem kanal
gebracht habe aber dass er bei vielen
sachen würde dass leute einfach die
flanken und da wir jetzt schon so bei
den kommentaren dabei sind würde ich
sagen jetzt aber mal ein paar kommentare
unter meinem video durch hat jemand
mitgezählt die oft luca ebenen gesagt
hat
leute ich gucke jetzt nicht mehr ganz so
wie die normalen arbeit wirklich wo oft
entwicklung gesagt ich meine kommentare
546 leichter das muss ja schon ein
bisschen was gewesen sein
dieser moment den senioren besser gta
spritztour die besser waren wirklich
luca spiel du mal gta 5 bitte leute ich
habe ja schon mal eine gta 5 channels
hochgeladen mit max und apple wenn ihr
wollt wie definiert vielleicht noch mal
oder öfter hochladen
dann lass einfach mal leicht bei diesem
video da weil ich hab hier auf meinem pc
beta blocker play sie also ich könnte es
theoretisch hochladen nicht beim alten
nur nicht was zu finden die tiger nicht
gab weil ich will etwas machen was jeder
youtuber da macht mein vater wird gerade
neben ihr auf der couch und gucke ich
das video an normalerweise sagt dem
abbau dieses youtube-video kriegen die
wir für geld mit ein paar videos vorbei
findet hat man damit ist die arbeit rein
steckt jedenfalls die fahrer aufgepasst
und jetzt kommt so ein schwachsinn
dieser typ verletzte sagt er
sowas ist cool der typ ist echt korrekt
luca mein respekt an die ich meinem
vater mit youtube unterhalten werden für
die findet er sinnlos
das liegt nicht an mir sondern an euch
dass ihr so aktiv seid was like saniert
und kommentare und so also danke ich
finde es gut wenn er die ganze zeit
meinen namen schreibt ich liebe evelyn
politiker namentlich vertreten
ich habe einen richtigen lack glas dort
aus so witzig kommentiert das war so
lustig ja wie gesagt die macht
vielleicht bald öfter nochmal wie
krieger ein topf von deinem shop
welcher shop hilfe etwa noch mal hier
der hat auf diesen namen
ach ja und leute zwanzigster dritter wie
gesagt hätte inter länder eintragen da
kommen zwei neue hinweise ein hut in
zwei verschiedenen farben aber auch 1000
signiertes dicke ein schluck von
irgendwas für jedes evelin okay sie
macht daraus direkten trinkspiel
allerdings ob ich so oft in berlin
gesagt habe hier fährt wieder irgendwie
einer von kommentar von wegen ich hätte
mich nur veränderten der mann konnte
nicht mehr die kernaussage ist bislang
zufrieden mit seinen leistungen oder ich
will nicht unterstellen geht es dir nur
um das geld und den film dinge denn an
die content einbringt die wird video
hier sollte eigentlich wirklich nur
fröhlich klein bisschen nett auf die von
denen eigentlich auf das anlage video
von den senioren aber ich kann natürlich
nicht ignorieren
ich hab früher sehr häufig gesagt hat
sich solche kommentare werde lange
antwortet habe allerdings voll kommt man
dann wieder nur eine antwort und dann
nicht endende konversation die man dann
führt deswegen hier mal eine ganz kurze
sache noch mal am ende des videos gleich
die ent card ich habe mich noch nicht
von der person verändert also hey ich
bin immer noch der dude der irgendwo in
köln in seiner bude wohnt studiert und
irgendwelche video hochlädt und nur weil
ich noch keine kraft mehr mache mich da
nicht ein ganzer kontinent verändert
meinen stempel das was ich mache hier
wirklich in seinem kommentar als die
content ab und da denke ich mir nur so
was mache ich denn für sie konnten
andere youtuber begehen straftaten ihren
video wie 24 stunden unternehmen
einschließen andere beleidigen schule in
ihren video oder andere nutzen
geschwafel und behinderte dauernd als
beleidigungen und hate andere fang an zu
singen nur um geld damit zu machen jeder
soll sein ding auf youtube machen ist
meint das was sie machen ich bin jetzt
auch nicht jemand der sich videos von
der moschee rapport oder so angucken
übels über die herzlichkeit nur sehr
manchmal dass ich das halt nicht so gut
halte vielleicht auch mal an die hater
brauten die mich wirklich nicht so gern
mögen
das macht was was müsste ich denn machen
damit ich sag mal damit ihr mich gehört
ich weiß nicht ich will mich nicht
verstellen
minecraft mache mir wirklich in letzter
zeit nicht mehr so viel spaß deswegen
lade ich halt nicht mehr so viel hoch
aber das was ich jetzt mache so ich
finde dass also ich mit sicherheit avi
content betiteln aber ich will auch
nicht in so eine richtung drängen
da wartete mit dem video meine damen und
herren ich wollte dass sie wirklich gar
nicht allzu lang fassen jetzt hier ich
wollte euch nur mitteilen die haben
wirklich darauf reagiert haben ein video
dazu gemacht hey das ist einfach hey das
ist wirklich ein großes herz und alle
beteiligten ihr findet jetzt ins michael
eingeblendet wenn ihr da draufsteht
könnte meinen kanal abonnieren eventuell
werde ich die nächste noch mal auf der
bühne und rocken video reagieren da oben
findet auch meine top eingeblendet und
hier nochmal das video wo ich das erste
mal auf die senioren pocken gta reagiert
habe also schaut euch das an
de croo